[Music]
everyone loves puzzles but a true hacker
would never be happy with his regular
size bubbles so Sylvan tuve decided to
create these in the woods outside
carrots it looks like you get to be a
kid again and play with bubbles but but
you're an adult which means you can do
it enormous Lee and no one can tell you
to stop almost three hundred thousand of
us have seen Sylvan such but just how
does he get him so big the whole thing
that govern fish is surface tension now
Walter had a very high surface tension
and this is because water molecules like
spend time bound to other water
molecules they don't that like spend
time interacting with the air and if you
make a giant bubble you're actually
making a very large surface that is in
contact with the air so you're gonna
need to add some kind of chemical that
will lower the surface tension like soap
soap molecules have two parts one part
that is very happy being in contact with
water and another part that is very
happy being in contact with the air what
you have is a very very thin layer of
water with soap molecules on either side
of it so you can think of the edge of a
bubble as like a sandwich
it's got soap molecules tiny bit of
water more soap molecules and this
dramatically lowers the surface tension
of the bubble and allows you to have
these giant shapes and gives you
elasticity so that the bubbles can move
and deform without popping so how do
certainly stop its big bubbles from
immediately bursting bubbles burst when
the water in the soap film sandwich all
evaporates so to stop them from bursting
you have to stop the evaporation and
this guy's done two things he's put
glycerol in the solution which is kind
of a sugary substance and that means the
water evaporates a lot slower he's also
doing this on a very damp humid day and
because there's more moisture in the air
around the bubble the water inside the
film is evaporating a lot of slower so
by using some clever chemistry
Silvan created a bubbly
there's not only a lot of science going
on here but I think there's also a lot
of skill going on I think sylveon has
practiced in his giant bubble making
forests